mais en attendant on vous pose donc une
question ce soir richard ferrand doit-il
démissionner c'est la question qui est
posée sur le figaro.fr
c'est la question qui qu'on se pose
depuis que la nouvelle est tombée cette
nuit la mise en examen dont pour prise
illégale d'intérêt alors en cause ce
sont des locaux qui avaient été loués
par des locaux qui appartenait à la
campagne de richard ferrand qui avait
été loué par les mutuel de bretagne qui
était dirigée alors par richard ferrand
lave la sphère l'avait conduit à
démissionner en 2010 est de son poste de
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
mais là pas question l'elysée le
gouvernement vole à son secours à
commencer par la porte parole
si bête ndiaye sur europe 1 ce matin où
est ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
d'abord richard ferrand et mise en
examen donc jusqu'à preuve du contraire
il est présumé innocent c'est important
de faire cette distinction parce que les
mots donnent l'impression que ce qui lui
est reproché est avérée et que
finalement d'ores et déjà on peut le
condamner si ce n'est par la justice au
moins moralement après oui il est
logique que le président de la
république et c'est effectivement le cas
lui conserve toute sa confiance
d'abord parce que c'est un homme loyal
droit qui a eu un parcours je crois
politique exemplairement alors c'est pas
du tout l'avis de l'association anticor
à l'origine de la ferme de la faire et
son avocat notamment estiment que ferran
doit quitter le perchoir en écoute pour
nous il doit partir oui en raison tout
simplement de l' équilibre des pouvoirs
et de la manière dont les institutions
doivent fonctionner je pense qu'en tout
état cause la responsabilité publique la
responsabilité des hommes publics la
responsabilité de ceux qui exercent des
fonctions de représentation démocratique
devrait pouvoir analyser les choses en
tirant les conséquences c'est-à-dire en
démissionnant lorsque bien évidemment
leur fonction ne leur permet plus
d'exercer avec sérénité
alors si bête ndiaye aux anticorps
camarades génie smadja il faut choisir
son camp
si richard ferrand s'applique à lui-même
ce qu'il préconisait pour les autres en
2017 et le problème de notre monde
d'aujourd'hui c'est que quand on
propositions sur twitter ça laisse des
traces
et donc quand on retrouve les tweets de
richard ferrand
au moment notamment de la sphère fillon
richard ferrand défendez l'idée que dès
lors que l'on ait mis en examen quelle
que soit la responsabilité que l'on
exerce au au sein de l'état on doit on
doit démissionner voilà donc si la
baisse il s'applique à lui-même ce qu'il
disait pour les autres alors oui il doit
démissionner maintenant moi je pense
qu'ils le moi je n'ai pas un point de
vue machiavélique là dessus moi je crois
le problème c'est la cohérence c'est à
dire que à partir du moment où on dit
voilà il existe une jurisprudence
politiques éthiques
cette jurisprudence c'est que quand on
est mis en examen
on reste présumé innocent ça c'est le
premier plan donc voilà on va le
président lissouba mais pour des raisons
qui sont liées à la crédibilité et à la
nécessité de ne pas porter atteinte à la
crédibilité de la parole publique
alors du coup on se met en retrait en
attendant le jugement c'est un point de
vue qui peut se défendre
voilà mais en tout cas même si à partir
du moment où on estime qu' il faut être
cohérente c'est à dire ou bien dans tous
les cas de figure on démissionne ou bien
on ne démissionne jamais mais on peut
pas démissionner à la carte ça peut pas
être ben quand je suis nommé ministre de
la cohésion des territoires
j'ai un je suis mise en examen
exactement dans la même affaire lâche
démissionne mais par contre pour la mise
en examen sur un autre volet de la même
affaire là par contre je peux rester
alors que c'est quand même président de
l'assemblée nationale ça n'est pas rien
quand même
je salue nicole bru nitot w en lorraine
les gens aux états unis pays que vous
connaissez bien
ferron réduite déjà démissionné non
système est très différent mais c'est
vrai que je trouve qu'en france on a
parfois une tolérance et un peu élargie
pour des personnalités publiques qui ont
de vrais ennuis avec la justice donc de
ce côté là je dois avancer pas le cas de
françois bausch exactement donc
j'aimerais moi je souscris à ce qui
vient d'être dit il ya une question de
cohérence s'il avait démissionné une
première fois et à un poste qui en en ce
sens était moins exposé je trouve que là
en tant que président de l'assemblée
nationale
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
mais non dans le cadre d'un gouvernement
qui ont le souvient avait mis la
moralisation de la vie publique en toute
première tête de ses priorités
l arrivée d'emmanuel macron au pouvoir
donc ça me paraît très cohérent et on a
demandé à françois de rugy de
démissionner pour moins que ça en
quelque sorte c'était juste une petite
histoire de homard non là les faits qui
sont reprochés à richard ferrand sont
graves
ce qu'il met en avant lui pour sa
défense aussi c'est que après la
première série d'auditions etc
si j'ai bien compris ça a été classée
sans suite donc ça ça lui donne aussi
des raisons de penser que peut-être il a
de quoi se défendre dans ce dossier mais
moi je serais plutôt d'avis qu'il doit
démissionner des coûts daniel vous
pensez il ay la raison s'accrocher ou
pas comme témoin dans cette affaire
n'ayant pas vu de photos ni demain ni de
langoustes je peux difficilement juger
aujourd'hui parce que quand même
aujourd'hui toutes les affaires si on à
partir d'une histoire de mutuelles c'est
dans cette danse est un oui alors il n'y
a pas de photos qui me permettrait de
juger monsieur fait renforce trêve de
plaisanterie moi je considère que la
différence de ce qu'il avait fait la
première fois en 2010 est cette fois ci
considère qu'il a été jugé et qu'il a
été considéré comme innocent sur cette
même affaire donc il se dit ça va il ya
une association qui me veut qu'ils m'en
veux à mort mais je ne veux pas leur cd
c'est un peu différent il ya eu un
jugement dans cette affaire la même
affaire même si on a pris peut-être
d'autres éléments donc lui considère
qu'il a été jugé et donc il ne veut pas
sur une passe qu'il peut y avoir aussi
une troisième association qui va venir
revenir une troisième fois le harcelait
et c'est là je peux comprendre son
jugement
mais c'est pas là ce n'est pas
l'association qui l'a mis en examen
c'est un juge
oui j'entends bien mais sur la demande
d'une association alors qu'ils lui
considère j'ai été jugés une fois ça va
entre l'avenue par combat en bas on m'a
blanchi etc etc
donc je bouge - je comprends son son
raisonnement alors maintenant les faits
qui lui sont reprochés à l'époque aussi
je veux dire on sait pas il n'a pas
vraiment fait bénéficier à sa famille
puisque on dit que c'était sa compagne
ils étaient ni pacsé ni mariés donc
c'est quelqu'un qu'il connaissait
peut-être ça la vous signer une
différence importante aussi dans la
sphère c'est pas madame fillon s'est pas
etc etc
c'est quelque chose qui est amex à sa
vie personnelle donc mais moi je pense
que pour l'essentiel
je comprends sa réaction en disant j'ai
été jugé assez alors nicole je sors nous
dit même si la mise en examen de richard
ferrand n'est pas synonyme de
culpabilité ou est elle la nouvelle
politique honnête de macron c'est vrai
qu'on souvient qu'il avait quand même
été élu pendant la campagne ils ont fait
campagne sur vous verrez nous on sera
différent des autres
les mains sales contre les mains propres
nous on fait de la politique intègre
tout ce monde là c'est derrière nous et
je reprends le terme que vous que vous
étiez tout à l'heure c'est là vous étiez
tous les deux le terme de cohérence on
remet la la loi de la moralisation de la
vie publique au caire 2 au coeur du
début du quinquennat aujourd'hui quand
même riche en fer c'est le quatrième
personnage de l'état au rang
protocolaire
donc c'est pas n'importe qui après est
ce que ça veut dire aussi qu'il faut que
tous les députés qui sont mis en examen
démissionne parce qu'il y en a un
certain nombre tout cela répond c'est
pas hyper trancher dans cette crise qui
est ce qui est assez surprenant c'est
que les politiques se sont tassées
retenue dans leurs réactions depuis
depuis ce matin il ya effectivement
d'autres d'autres affaires qui sont en
cours on a eu l'audition de françois
bayrou et marielle de sarnez la
polémique qui rebondit sur les
perquisitions chez mélenchon et la
convocation de jean marie le pen
tout ça c'est la même affaire c'est la
sphère des assistants parlementaires du
parlement européen on a quand même un
peu l'impression qu'ils jugeront vite se
faire les politiques mais
moi ce que je retiens surtout c'est que
tout ça là le cumul de la médiatisation
des affaires au même moment
tout ça n'est pas très bon il faut bien
voir que les politiques des juges
117-110 qui fait jour à midi
je venais de parler comme lui ce qui
paraît non si enfin si l'objectif
recherché par cette mise en lumière
c'est de monter qu'on est comme dans une
société transparente tout ça ou où on ne
cache rien où on va on fait je suis pas
sûr que cet objectif soit atteint dans
l'opinion publique je ne pense pas
qu'ils soient au contraire maintenant
dans une ère de lynchage médiatique il y
avait plus besoin du du partisan du bien
qui il veut vaincre le mal il ya la
presse s'empare de deux problèmes comme
ça et à elle seule elle se met à je veux
dire le terme lynchage il n'est pas il
n'est pas inexact c'est les médias eux
mêmes qui se chargent du lynchage
ils n'ont plus besoin l'interlocuteur
n'ont plus besoin d'interlocuteurs c'est
ça alors j'associe ça au phénomène de
internet g1 sauf si ça au phénomène de
des télévisions continue etc
c'est un qui ont besoin comme disait ma
mère avec avec une cerise ils font un
clafoutis c'est ça ça encourage ça ça
encourage une affaire comme celle-là
c'est quelque chose qui n'aurait pas
qu'ils n'auraient pas émergé comme ça il
ya dix ans moi je pense que c'est au
président de la république de définir la
règle pour son camp pour sa famille
politique pour sa majorité
c'est à lui de dire ou de ne pas dire à
partir du moment où il ya une mise en
examen
on ne peut plus exercer une fonction de
premier plan comme la jurisprudence
balladur
oui bien sûr on dont il doit le dire ou
alors il dit écoutez nez on vous a mise
en examen la mise en examen ce n'est pas
un signe de culpabilité et donc non il
n'ya mais il doit déterminer là elle
peut pas être appliquée à la carte alors
un coup on démissionne un conte
démissionne pas non çà çà çà ça
discrédite complètement le politique aux
autres aux yeux de l'opinion et ça ça
c'est ça qui va pas mais justement on
avait diminué le terme la force des mots
ont d'abord on disait inculpé maintenant
on dit mise en examen ce qui veut bien
dire qu'on suppose que cette personne
n'est pas forcément coupable avant quand
on disait vous êtes inculpés ça veut
dire vous étiez presque aux portes de la
prison
mais le lynchage médiatique c'est une
chose un juge qui met quelqu'un examen
ou moi j'ai tendance à avoir confiance
dans les institutions de notre pays
quand même je pense que les juges ne met
pas les gens en examen quand il ya
vraiment rien dans un dossier
je peux me tromper mais je pense que
c'est aussi dangereux de commencer à
mettre non mais et heureusement mais je
crois à la présomption d'innocence mais
pour croire à la présomption d'innocence
il faut aussi croire qu'on a un système
de justice qui fonctionne et donc moi
que on demande aux hommes politiques
d'être irréprochable cdc des questions
prise illégale d'intérêts et corruption
s'est c'est vraiment moyen quand même
dans un climat aussi très tendue
socialement y compris politiquement pour
le gouvernement c'est quand même pas
terrible de s'accrocher personnage qui
crée le doute de cette façon c'est ce
que estime en tout cas babineau qui nous
dit ce nouveau monde ressent très
fortement à l'ancien ça fragilise
énormément l'image des politiques aux
yeux des français et leur confiance dans
les institutions et brownie ce midi le
problème est quand même aussi
l'instrumentalisation éventuelle de la
justice en france c'est ce que reproche
effectivement mélenchon
à emmanuel macron je vous vois pas cette
remarque non même temps on peut
s'interroger sur effectivement le fait
que les hommes politiques ou les femmes
politiques ne fassent pas plus attention
à la manière dont ils conduisent on dise
leur vie quoi
c'est ça c'est à dire quand on veut être
présent dans le public comme françois
fillon se fait pas offrir de costumes ce
qu'il ya de plus terrible dans cette
affaire il faut se mettre à la place il
faut se mettre à la place des d'aider
des gens qui regardent le monde
politique de cette manière et le
sentiment que ça donne c'est qu'il ya
une sorte d'auto protection qui
s'organise et il ya une impunité comme
ça qu'ils s'organisent et ça ça c'est ce
que c'est ce qu'il ya de pire
aujourd'hui dans le la rupture du lien
de confiance entre l'opinion et la
politique
vous êtes près de 32000 plus de 32000
avoir voté à avoir répondu à la question
du figaro mise en examen richard ferrand
doit-il démissionner de la présidence de
l'assemblée nationale et pour l'instant
c'est un oui franc et massif on se
croirait un référendum du général de
gaulle années 60 ou de la nouvelle
calédonie en 1988
donc ça c'est votre avis également
plutôt bon il est aussi non non non je
ne le souhaite pas moi je pense que dans
les arguments qui ont été présentés au
début de l'émission il ya un peu de vrai
dans les deux jeunes choisis par et bien
sûr se touchent dans même temps vous
avez noté quand même l'argumentation de
la porte parole du gouvernement
si l'argumentaire
il est loyal à l'égard du président du
moment qu'on est loyal avec le président
ça va ya pas de problème